le pont le pont c'est bon pour le
commerce est mauvais pour l'équilibré
écologique de l'île de ré rétorquent les
verts les amoureux de la nature et de
nombreuses autres vous avez déjà entendu
ce type d'argument et l'heure n'est plus
à la discussion on inaugure
officiellement aujourd'hui le pont qui
fait d'hériter c'est à dire les
habitants de l'île de ré des presque
continentaux et pourtant il ya encore
des irréductibles 10% environ des
habitants de l'île pour eux ils disent
on verra à l'usagé qu'ils avaient raison
et le débat vous allez l'entendre est
toujours aussi passionnelle entre les
adversaires du pont qui parle de
désastre de catastrophe écologique
ellis par exemple que les canards
sauvages ont déserté l'île et les
partisans du pot qui eux mettent en
avant bien sûr les avantages pour les
habitants de l'île le débat est loin
d'être clos reportage rennais ross
charlotte angibaud l'une des hautes
figures de la résistance au pont épouse
d'un charpentier de navires elle fut
professeur de lettres mais aujourd'hui
il pourrait tout aussi bien enseigné le
droit depuis qu'elle s'est
personnellement chargé de rédiger
plusieurs recours devant le tribunal
administratif pour que l'île de ré ne
devienne part et la ville dit elle mais
charlotte et et tout ce qu'il voulait
pas du pont ont perdu depuis trois mois
chaque jour 6000 véhicules ont moins
emprunté ouvrage deux fois plus au temps
du back lille n'était pas prête à
recevoir tant demande
il aurait fallu une discipline une
mentalité vraiment sage de sa geste il
n'y avait pas l'argent de milito et on
n'a pas compris que l'argent n'était
qu'un signe et que on allait perdre des
choses tellement précieuse et aussi je
dirais perdre son âme
cela fait des années que les antilles
puntistes ont livré bataille au nom de
la défense de l'environnement et de la
préservation de l' équilibre fragile de
l'île de ré la blanche le plus souvent
propriétaires de résidences secondaires
il perd à l'occasion un peu vite la
parole au nom des habitants permanents
cela les red s'est apprécié aujourd'hui
pour la plupart la fin de l' isolement
et la possibilité de pouvoir nuitées
jour désormais se rendre sur le
continent
en quelques minutes
les commerçants en tête ils savent bien
que 60% des revenus de l'île sont le
fruit du tourisme
peut-être certains résidents secondaires
qui viennent ici chercher le calme et le
repos après une année de vie urbaine
difficile préférerait trouver ici lé
désert mais enfin le désert ça
supposerait que d'autres sont partis et
je pense qu'il serait égoïste de
souhaiter le départ des autres on doit
aussi vivre avec les autres et penser
que en ce qui concerne l'environnement
gain les résidences secondaires n'ont
pas toujours été la bonne manière de
protéger l'environnement et avec un brin
de provocation françois blaizot ajoute
que le pont lui favorisera la protection
lille en ayant contraint à prendre des
mesures rigoureuses notamment contre
l'urbanisation sauvage
il n'est que grand temps dira t'on la
dégradation de lille était déjà en cours
le pont ne pourrait que l'accélérer la
tâche sera rude car à la mer ou à la
montagne qui peut se vanter d'avoir
réalisé l'accord parfait entre tourisme
intensifs les préservation du site donc
à suivre